the 7th of
October the largest and deadliest
escalation of violence in decades the
last 100 days have seen the long running
conflict in the Middle East erupt in
horrific frenzy of
violence the United States stands with
Israel against this terrorism 300 people
were killed after a strike on a hospital
in central Gaza the intensity of the war
has been matched by the level of
bitterness and vitual here at home
American Jews have rallied across the US
in support of pal we're cop G Israel is
rocked by widespread
protests October the 7th was a setup
would you keep her massing power it's
not up to you what's your opinion you
are a mother racist please shut up
people don't know who to trust which
facts to believe and the only thing that
everyone agrees on is they have no faith
in the mainstream media we are coming
away from this mainstream media
completely twist the facts that's why
I'm here in the heart of London to
attend a massive Pro Palestine protest
speak directly to the people involved
and show you what's actually happening
on the
[Music]
ground so here we are uh third video
that we are doing from the protest today
is supposed to be absolutely giant so we
will see this is of course London Bridge
an iconic place here in the central
London you can see tower bridge over
there uh behind us and we're heading to
the protest which is going to start at
bank uh just ahead of us up there uh and
we will see how big it is and what's
going on of course we'll talk to people
and find out why they're here and what
they're up
to thank you very
much perfect thank you mate no worries
take care all right this is obviously
day two of uh the US and the UK bombing
uh the houthi militias who've been
attacking commercial vessels in the Red
Sea
and um this is a front page of the
Socialist worker in the top right there
it says West threatens to ignite a wider
war in the Middle East the United States
and Britain are targeting the Yemen
houthi militia which is a sign that
imperialism is entering an even more
vicious
phase so there you go this was a pound
freedom for Palestine you want to sign
brilant thank you so
much come sign if you agree Palestine
must be free say no to Israeli aart side
say no to genocide what brings you here
today uh yeah the genocide in Gaza of
the Palestinian people what do your sign
say it says when my friend did this so
it's only Israel can G Israel it says
right Israel that was uh and why do you
call it Israel I I didn't make this P
out actually but someone just just
handed it to me but yeah I've heard it
heard it used before yeah and I hear
people saying uh from The River To The
Sea Palestine will be free uh do you
subscribe to that you um yeah kind of
with uh free where everyone could be
free in that land sort of together so uh
how would that happen um well everyone
could be live as equals so yeah so that
like ending um ending AAR uh and and and
how would that how would that come about
what needs to happen do you think in
your opinion for that to happen I think
so I think people uh realize that
everyone's equal um so I would be here
if um if this wasen to Israelis I'd feel
exactly the same if it was if uh
Israelis were being genocided for
example and what did you think of what
happened on October 7th how that does
that play into all this yeah I think
it's possibly a false flag event um it's
possibly I think there's there like
clear evidence that
um uh is Israel is partly responsible
for the formation of Hamas um and I
think it was clear clear evidence that
Israel had been warned that this attack
was coming sorry can you just turn your
ban I want to take a picture
of
sadly so so you think Israel's
responsible at least they knew it was
coming this attack was coming Egypt had
been warning like the intelligence um
there have been something like 7 hours
before Israel responded 1 2 3 4 OCC No 5
6 7 isra is terrorist you gave me this
and it shows some interesting things
that I hadn't heard before for you know
about uh what the prophet Muhammad said
about equality and about women and so on
and I was interested particularly the
the last one about terrorism uh and it
says that terrorism uh in the Quran
killing of innocent is compared to
killing uh the whole world all of
mankind can you tell us more about that
so in essence Islam does not allow the
kinning of Innocence under any
circumstances in Battlefield in Sur in
Sur verse in Surah 9:5 Often misquoted
by islamophobes to um somehow stipulate
that Islam um um allows the killing of
Innocence when it doesn't it's only when
you are in a battlefield and your enemy
is coming to you then in self-defense
you have to fight back which is given in
any form of yeah well in war you would
accept that of course October 7th would
that was that a terrorist attack in your
opinion so October 7 there are many
responses given to that I mean we have
to go back to 1917 1948 1967 the the
intricate involvement of the historical
events which have led up to these um you
know um these events that have occurred
so it's just a frustration and
overboiling we can but you said it's
forbidden to kill Innocents oh
absolutely it's forbidden to kill inoc
but they did right well that is what an
understanding is given there are
different understandings there is oh
really what's your understanding from
other sources that I've read um some
people are of the opinion that factions
of Hamas are in with the Israelis giving
them the pretext to do their acts others
um well I'm just giving you a thing
you're giving you a view I'm giving my
let him finish and I'll talk to you yes
no stick around I want to talk to you as
well yeah okay yeah so on that basis
other others take the view that um it's
just reacting to already being aware
that for example there are natural gas
reserves in in in Gaza which Israel has
become aware of and through that Red Sea
area where train is taking place where
the hoties are currently stopping
certain shipments going through what do
you believe I'm just curious cuz I'm
just I'm just stating from what you hear
I'm not there am I so I can't say if
it's slen what exactly has happened
others you're not there in Gaza either
but you're saying the genocide is
happening right but that's very clear
for all for us to see the actual bombing
is taking place in the death and
destruction but but seventh October
wasn't clear no that was absolutely
clear as well but we don't we're not we
can't be certain forever as to who done
these acts you see although Hamas can
make unilateral claims that is just
based upon certain factions there are
factions within them who said we had
nothing to do with it I'm a Hindu non
pristan I do support Israel in this you
got a right to defend I see all the
channels I listen to people you know
they're delusional unfortunately people
have a right to to respond there are
only 50 million Jews in the world you
know there are two billion Muslims you I
mean what is a ratio doing mate you know
it's a lot of [__] going on yeah you
know very interesting point and are you
here for the protest I'm here for the
protest to see what's going on I've
heard there's a lot of hasss here you
know you know that Rec who did you hear
that from oh I've heard it from a lot of
YouTube apostate channels you know they
come here infiltrate you know I want to
see if it's true or not you see yeah I I
mean look I'm a Hindu you know Hindu
temple was attacked last week by a
Muslim guy in Wembley you know we don't
we're a very peaceful successful
Community uh far more than the Muslims
yeah you know we you got Prime Ministers
[__] Hindu man you know so we don't
get involved only people like me will
get involved if I feel that we're being
attacked as well you know the Jews are
do you feel that Hindus are being
attacked in the UK now we are now huh
because they they're afraid of they're
not afraid of us they're jealous of us
of our success you know we don't have
any it's like you know there are 10,000
Muslims imprisoned is people aware of
this go and Google it it's all there you
know peders rapists terrorists there's
only 4% of of Hindus in prison from for
minor crimes like tax evasion you know
we're not an aggressive species unless
we're pushed have you been here before
to these protests in the past and and
what did you see what do you experience
well I've been to a couple now and
they're very well policed but I do not
see any police here
that's what worries me where are the
police can you see anybody there a lot
of undercover ones here look at what's
going
on you know I could be one you never
know you know man I don't watch you much
but I do follow you guys why not I like
I like what do you mean you don't watch
us much mate oh I know your channel I
don't listen to it very much I'll try
listen again I yeah put it on excuse me
mate we work hard distributed to my
group
[Music]
so I just noticed the signs you got from
The River To The Sea palestin will be
free what does that mean well it's quite
self-explanatory need to be well it's a
little bit more complicated than that
isn't it cuz I guess what I mean is how
would that come about what would happen
to the Israelis
Etc I
don't I'm trying to think of how to word
it isn't it just as self-explanatory as
the area of land it's palestine's land
yeah so when you say Palestine which bit
do you mean yeah the Gaza Strip g a
strip the West Bank West Bank yeah
that's
it I don't know is that is there I
thought it was self-explanatory I'm
getting confused I thought it was
self-explanatory what either are you
[__] question it's a [__]
question why well tell me why is it I'm
not [__] getting involved in this but
it's
so like inflam right no it's yeah it's
just really
inflammatory asking what that timeing
it's inflammatory whyat though I'm not
getting
involved okay all right I didn't say
anything I was just asking what it meant
Oh do you agree with the sign yeah I
agree yeah of course and what does it
mean to you the Palestinians to be free
you know uh in well it says Palestine so
I was asking them which bit of the area
yeah the people that being oppressed for
them to be free you know Gaza West Bank
them people to be free yeah Gaza and
West Bank yeah Ians in general you know
cuz we know that what's going on all of
them are being oppressed so for them to
be free you know it's nothing nothing
you know it's clear as day you know yeah
yeah yeah I was just asking them which
bit of the land they mean because some
people mean all of the land including
the bit where Israel is now and that's
why there's some debate about you know
what that means I the main message is
Palestinians that are being oppressed
for them to be free you know and for
everyone to live in harmony regardless
of your religion or whatever it is
because historically speaking
the we say Muslims Jews Christians have
been living there for centuries you know
living in good peace but when early in
recent times all of this issue has been
start going on you know but I think it's
how long how long would you say this
issue has been going on as far as I know
obviously I'm not as educated on this
topic for example with other people but
for roughly around 75 years since I
think the Mandate from 45 just after
World War I think is when the issues you
know when PE when the British came and
started cutting up lands and taking the
the the lands of the Palestinians I
think that's when the issue started you
know well yeah before that you had the
Ottoman Empire there which had very
strong control over the area yeah that
makes sense any attack on civilians is
not justified you know regardless of of
whatever happened you know but I think
the the the issue really should what is
the origin of this problem you know
history has not started October 7 you
know we have to see the real origin of
this was as I said 75 years ago
obviously I'm not as educated on this
topic but for cuz what I see now is this
whole issue is being portrayed as
if civilization and history started from
October 7th and onwards but no that's
not the real that's all you expect the
whole issue is obviously as we said from
you know 70 80 years ago and I think
that contributes to what is going on
today from from both sides you know from
the Palestinian side as well as the
Israeli side all right so we are now
heading off from towards Parliament
which is where the protest is supposed
to and it's kind of loose at the moment
uh not there is a lot of people here but
it's not jamack as we've seen at some
other protests we've had a few
conversations with people obviously um
very interesting takeaways I mean when
you talk to people about what let's say
from The River To The Sea means a lot of
them don't really you know we had one
group that said it was self-explanatory
and when I asked them to explain it
didn't really happen the other thing I
noticed straight away is the the people
we've talked to so far whenever you ask
them about October 7th most of them
there are exceptions but most of them
basically intimate that they don't think
that it really happened or if it did it
was caused by uh Israel working with
Hamas or was some kind of false flag
operation or whatever um which is you
know one of the big challenges of the
modern world is everyone's got their own
information uh everyone has their own
facts and if everyone's got their own
facts it's very difficult to understand
how you're ever going to reach some kind
a mutual understanding or agreement
about the way that things are so we'll
carry on speaking to people and find out
what else they
[Music]
think Rak apparently wanted for genocide
so watch out mate they're
coming so we're approaching St Paul's
which is just up there uh St Paul's
Cathedral uh and it's starting to get
busy still haven't seen a single police
officer uh since we got into the main
section of the protest but we're about
to get into a really busy part hopefully
we will see uh more people and chat to
them there's no nice way to say it
[__] sort it out stop killing kids
basically get out of [__] Gaza and
leave the Palestinians alone you
bastards my one sentence would be please
please please stop bombing the little
children of Gaza it is breaking the
hearts of the mothers of the world and
breaking the heart of everyone [__]
Israel and go suck your mom that's what
I would say first and foremost second
and foremost go back to your land
palestin is not your land the president
you are from Poland I know this is more
than one sentence but still just go and
suck your mom stop bombing work for
peace build a new Workers Party a
socialist alternative to sunak and Sama
for a socialist in what's a socialist in
if I'm being honest with you I just got
this at the stand over over there okay
uh I don't actually know the definition
of the word inap okay but I mean do any
of you know the definition of the word
inap stop bombing Gaza that makes sense
what about that one from the river to
the Sea yeah and what does that mean
what does that mean uh well it it means
to that it's uh to stop the Israeli
occupation of uh of Palestine from which
river to which
sea River Jordan the west from from the
Jordan
to the Mediterranean Sea yeah so does
that mean that all of Israel should be
uh what is now Israel should be
Palestine in your opinion no I
personally don't think that I think
there's I mean this I'm definitely not
the person to talk to about this but I
know that there's multiple strategies
that people come up with like a
two-state solution or one state solution
I think ideally I would like to see one
multifaith state that is neither Israel
nor
Palestine walking with this protest
there's definitely a much younger
demograph graic here than the March
against anti-Semitism which we attended
at the end of last year that matches up
well with the evidence which shows that
young people are more likely to support
Palestine than Israel in this
[Music]
conflict all right so those are the
first two police officers we've seen so
far but then again I have to say there's
doesn't seem to be any particular need
for them everything is going very
peacefully no one is there's nothing UNT
going
on
[Music]
[Applause]
most are mainstream media yes and
notably the BBC okay and what would you
say is a good alternative for people to
get information uh I would name a few
Middle East ey democracy Now
um um Double Down
News they're all uh they're curent
they're alternative media that are more
impartial and more factual uhhuh in
terms of the BBC for example what would
you say the main things that they've got
wrong about this
conflict completely twist the facts
twist the truth yeah like like what can
you give us some examples an an easy
example just from yesterday the court uh
you know the file filing of the court of
just um the genocide claim against uh
Israel by South Africa by South Africa
is uh BBC covers the defense by Israel
but does not actually cover the claim
made by South Africa that's just one
basic example just from
[Music]
yesterday let make
some we want Bo we want we want sanction
we
want in our thousands in our Millions
free free
freee free
[Music]
pal we have broken off from the main
protest which is just up ahead of us
we're here on the embankment walking
along uh a few thoughts on the day so
far very interesting contrast with the
protest against anti-Semitism that we
went to last year not a single British
flag very interesting just just an
observation uh which I thought was very
interesting the other difference is
there's lots of chanting I complained
about it at the protest against that not
enough of that going on here there's
almost you have to say too much of that
going on it's interesting being part of
it or being in it because it gets you
into this group tribal State the
chanting the singing and it it's a very
powerful tool which I'm sure has been
used for thousands of years to get
people to kind of feel part of a group
and suspend their own identity within it
to be chanting and repeating things that
as we've seen in conversation a lot of
people don't really know what it is that
they mean or haven't really thought very
carefully about them but it gives them a
sense of belonging gives them a sense of
group U tribal
identity I've been to every every march
with Palestine well this round anyway um
same as everyone else don't agree with
genocide speaking to protesters at the
March against anti-Semitism they feel
that Israel was attacked and so it's
going to respond and when you have
people hiding in among buildings and
densely populated areas you are going to
get a lot of Civilian casualties but
it's because Israel is having to make
sure there's no terrorist threat on his
border that's what they would say well
they would say that wouldn't they I mean
would you say I would say that anybody
who was engaged in genocide they wanted
to kill people wanted to kill as many
civilians as they could would you use an
excuse like that that's what I would say
so would you say that Israel is
deliberately targeting civilians I have
a speaker you have a speaker I have a
microphone yeah I have lots of
Palestinian active activist shes if you
can call them that um can you give us
one yeah yeah yeah go for it let's do
[Music]
it we see ourselves as one big family
this whole world's a family we don't
care for each other we don't have lose
that that humanistic nature then
everything's gone everything's lost so
we're here grieving for our brothers and
sisters who are losing who are suffering
and we're here just to show our support
are you seik yeah it's interesting
because we met a Hindu guy here who was
completely uh very pro- Israel but you
guys are clearly on on the side of the
Palestinians I'm guessing we're we're
here for any where where there's
Injustice says you will find seeks so
where you find people who are downtrod
doesn't matter where they're from what
community from we for the PO for all we
believe in the Oneness and every in
everybody so we will not see any
difference in anybody but where someone
is being downtrodden with the seats of
stand with them we need a ceasefire
right now don't we so what else would I
be here for and and how will that happen
[Music]
how so how will the ceasefire happen
What should who should do what in your
opinion the UK the us all the
international Powers whoever's out there
that can control this right now we need
to stop so we can communicate we cannot
communicate if we don't if we keep
fighting each other so cease fire right
now and then we can move on from there a
cease fire means seizing from both sides
fire which is what we're asking for so
we're not asking for one side or the
other we're just saying stop the bombing
stop the wars so you're talking to both
sides is what you're saying everyone
stop killing just stop and then we can
have a conversation about what's coming
next but right now as we're having
conversations and people are still dying
what's the point yeah so see fire that's
where we need to start all right well
thanks for talking to us appreciate
cheers have a nice day going ask you
what a socialist in would look
like you don't want to talk to us fair
enough no one wants to tell us what a
socialist in is it's very annoying
what's your name my name is Constantine
what's yours is it Constantine chrisen
yes um I'm quite busy you okay no
worries hi have I seen you on GB
news I haven't been on GB news for like
a year but you might have done yeah I
mean I also speak on the B Wars yes yeah
cuz I was on your side tell us about the
Workers Party and why you're here we're
here to show our to show solidarity with
the people of Palestine with the people
of Yemen who are just being bombed what
brings you here today is a reason why
like thing the Israel the reason why
they're killing kids and like how since
October how many kids have dead because
of Israel can I ask why you all have
your faces covered I'm just curious no
we're just having no face c c it's cold
yeah it's cold okay open if you want say
again open if you want oh no no I'm just
asking that's all and have you been to
these protest before do you come
regularly the reason why we're here is
because that Israel is killing and
murdering kids and we need the war to
wake up wake up guys and why do you
think Israel is doing this cuz they want
land I feel like they want land they
want land so I I see you've got a sign
there says journalism that get paid for
selling lies and I'm guessing that's
Pierce Morgan right yes okay and on the
right journalism that pays the price for
telling the truth who's
that and who is he he is the man of
Truth man of Bravery he's the one who
sacrificed all his family for the cause
of Gaza and did not move out of Gaza
insisted to be there why do you say that
this is journalism that's selling
lies um it's very obvious what is going
on all the lies about what happened on
the October 7th the justification for
the genocide they're all based on Lies
when you say lies about October 7th what
do you mean all those allegations that
we never saw any footages of of
decapitated children that Pierce Morgan
always asked about and all those women
that get got uh gang raped uh in uh
contrast we saw so many hostages freed
they were talking about the good
treatment they had and during the
Captivity
[Music]
now obviously one of the things that
we've talked a lot about in these videos
in the past is the fact that the way the
mainstream media is covering these
issues isn't always reliable and you see
that at this protest and every other one
we've covered what publication you read
or what news you watch determines what
you think and what you think the facts
are of any given
situation that's why we've tried to do
these videos by talking to people
directly and give you a picture of
what's actually happening on the ground
without the filter of the media choosing
and picking what it is you see which is
why we are incredibly proud to partner
with ground news for this video ground
news is a platform that allows you to
make sure that the information you're
getting is balanced by showing you how
every single newspaper is covering the
various topics that are being discussed
and gives you a sense of how the right
and leftwing in other Publications are
covering specific issues for example the
big story in the news at the moment is
the fact that South Africa has accused
Israel of committing genocide and when I
go on the ground news app on my phone I
can see that there are more than 500
sources reporting on this and according
to ground news I can see the breakdown
so there's 30% of the coverages coming
from the left and the left-wing
Publications will tend to use phrases
like Israel's propaganda Israel lashes
back Etc while right leaning
Publications will be using phrases like
Israel defends itself South Africa
hypocrisy Etc and I can see how that is
being split in the bias insides tab as
well that will highlight the differences
my favorite featur is the blind spot
which shows you stories that are
disproportionately covered either by the
left or the right and that allows you to
make sure that you're not stuck in an
echo chamber so if you believe in
nuanced fact-based discussion and seeing
things with your own eyes as we're
showing you here then head to ground do
news for/ trigonometry and you can get
30% of their unlimited Vantage plan
access that's ground. news/ trigonometry
to get 30% off the unlimited access
Vantage plan and now let's head back to
the
protests to wrap up the day we walked
past Downing Street and into parlament
square where various figures gave
speeches throughout the day including
Jeremy Corbin we didn't catch Jeremy's
speech but we did run into his brother
Piers who gave us some interesting
thoughts on the situation well we got
two SS here first first of all to make
it clear it's not a war it's a genocide
and that Israel state is a key part of
the world economic Forum they completely
work together we want to defeat the
Israeli State and destroy the world
economic Forum well October the 7th was
a setup arranged and agreed by the
Israeli
government and a lot of the left group
soall don't even talk about that which
is pathetic it was organized by the
Israeli government the IDF itself killed
its own people in order to make it look
like herass it killed people I strongly
believe that we are coming away from
this mainstream media the BBC the CNN
you've got all of these who don't
actually bring out the true um
definition of what is journalism and I
feel think it's a disgrace that what
I've been seeing so far and as soon as a
person comes on the first thing they do
is say do you condemn Hamas and it's
absolutely ridiculous do I condemn Hamas
I don't condemn Hamas because I feel
that they're a a resistance Fighters and
I feel now yeah that they're not using
the gazans as human Shields that Israel
is putting down at it as they are
genuinely sitting there and fighting for
resistance thoughts on the day I shared
some of them with you before I think
there's a very interesting difference
demographically here and all sorts of
ways to the other protests we've seen
but also it's interesting I mean people
are saying that there's half a million
people here it didn't look like that to
me at all uh in Parliament Square itself
actually there were fewer people than
there were for the March against
anti-Semitism from what I could see so I
reckon it was probably more like 100
thousand which is what we saw at that
March as well it seemed more uh an
accurate figure to me the average age
being much lower here there is a hell of
a lot of young people and as you've seen
in the video not all of them being
diplomatic have thought carefully about
why they're here the pick up signs that
say social C don't really know what that
means you know the overall Vibe a lot of
the people that we spoke to here just
seem to be people who are very
compassionate who have a lot of empathy
for people who they think are oppressed
and to them I remember particularly one
guy who said something which I think
really sums it up which is it's not an
even fight or something along those
lines right one side is so much stronger
than the other which is a very
interesting way to look at it because if
you have a war you know as a party to a
conflict you would want to be a stronger
than the other party and the fact
that
Hamas provoked this and is now being
destroyed as a result with a lot of
Civilian casualties seems to me like
that's something that you would put on
them as opposed to saying well one side
is stronger they should um they should
hold back but anyway so that's another
takeaway from here I think there are a
lot of young people here who as I say I
don't think they've all of them have
thought as carefully about this issue as
you might hope so in terms of the
policing of this protest I have to say I
don't know I haven't looked on my social
media today we did not see any
anti-semitic pla cards you know from the
river to the sea is a separate
conversation but apart from that didn't
see any anything hateful really going on
didn't see anybody saying anything
hateful there was no violence there was
no destruction of property yeah some
people climbing on traffic lights and
stuff like that but but really this was
completely peaceful and I didn't really
see any issue with it that said there
were literally
almost no police here at all um there
was a lot fewer police here than there
were at the just upall protest which as
you saw in our last video there was
about 50 protesters and there was
probably more police than protesters but
then again they weren't necessary you
know like I say this was uh entirely
entirely peaceful so uh from a policing
perspective I didn't see anything out of
order today how have the media covered
this it's very hard to say because there
as we've been talking about throughout
the video there's all sorts of different
media uh organiz ation and platforms who
who all have their own view of this
issue I am a big critic of the way that
the BBC's gone but not so much because
of necessarily the way they've covered
certain issues but particularly when it
comes to their hiring and Staffing
policies the type of Comedy they make
they news broadcast make mistakes but
what I've saw saw today and also other
protest we've seen is the BBC are in a
very difficult position where it's sort
of everyone wants to take a shot at them
and there's a lot of shots to be taken
but actually it's hard to keep everybody
happy because you have a very polarized
society which has a lot of different
views of the same issues not least
because everyone now has their own fact
as we've talked about I think social
media is making it more difficult for
everybody to get accurate information
it's also making it easier but also more
difficult at the same time and the way
it makes it more difficult is if you
judge this protest that we just attended
based on the social media coverage of it
I very much doubt you would get an
accurate picture of it as we're about to
be arrested
on to the pment now there's somebody
who's a bit of a job's worth getting
excited so I think social media is
giving people an inaccurate picture of
things because it rewards the most
extreme things and I'm really pleased to
be doing these videos because what we
are trying to do is to show you the
reality on the ground as opposed to hey
here's a terrible thing that happened
grab your attention and that's just all
that happens I think it's really
important uh in this moment in
particular for people to be responsible
with the way that they're covering
things so we've shown you exactly what
has been happening here we haven't
sought out people who are more extreme
than others we've literally tried to
talk to a whole range of people and get
their take on it and show you the way
that this protest actually went down I
think the right to protest is very
important however having attended a
bunch of these protests I think that I
am much more cynical and skeptical about
the potential for these protests to
actually achieve anything constructive
that may be down to the types of
projects we've attended because a lot of
them they don't have any concrete
demands I think these projects more than
anything are a way to let people vent
about the things that they're not happy
about which is good because when people
are not allowed to vent then that anger
can build and take more violent uh form
so I think it's important that people
are able to come and voice their opinion
do I think that's actually going to make
any impact on what happens in the real
world no I don't thanks for giving us
your time and watching this video it is
people like you who make it possible for
us to do this kind of Journalism that
you saw today and make sure before you
go speaking of Journalism check out
ground news so that you get a balanced
perspective on all the issues that are
going on in the world smash that like
button make sure to subscribe and we'll
see you
[Music]
[Applause]
soon